welcome to this video playing concrete
again so I lost this Sicilian time model
of earlier and if you place the exactly
same line i have no improvement because
i didn't check it yet so let's go for
let's go back to basics my my outline am
in the in the chil'ren at least here I
mean I know it's not that great but at
least i know what's going on I know
where the danger is coming let's say and
for once I'm quick okay so you went for
that half for idea so one of one of the
way is forward for white I should check
it first it would have been a bit more
precise okay not a huge deal always glad
to exchange rooks here in this position
it helps quite a bit in defending
relatively speaking this position is
already okay anyway it can be much worse
so I got Knight f3 check theoretically
speaking as such helping me in any way
probably not on no not really so what am
I supposed to do here I can't Red
Queen's still not sure if that helps and
the night on g7 this is also something
that can be improved
Howard oh how do i improve that night
mone de is not helping a lot
I can play any of any movie basically
it's not like he's threatening anything
but it's not so clear what what I'm
doing I mean in terms of getting in
terms of going forward so what I can do
it and I sure if that helps play for
Quincy 8 + + h 5 / tears good night XP 5
a tactic
I don't really see a good way to improve
here anyway we're somewhere someway with
my nite nite xe5 would be cool to get
this this thing in but not it's not
really working I think so quince quince
e8 and then then aged five would be cool
but when i text b5 i have night XP five
now
I know sometimes are very impractical
and some positions i had tried tried to
do things even if I'm perfectly fine
with doing nothing and then I'm getting
into time pressure yeah like here I'm
doing something because I feel I can
which is may be true but it costs lots
of time and it's difficult at the end to
to continue the game normally night XP 5
is a move now leads to some crazy
complications check but ok decided to go
for this which also leads to have some
complications so what now Knight g4 or
what what exactly
yeah that will send all the risky
decision the whole thing here this can
take on g6 odd sound
now it wasn't a good idea h5 yeah this
is this is kind of now I'm doing things
I me could have just played any move and
I'm totally fine but I wanted to do
something active and it's probably
costing me check
nine f5 or threatening knight to e7 ok
and not sure that is so dangerous check
my chief alone time warning
and it looks difficult check my night
only aid is not very good to put it
mildly
I had super passive it says something
more active that I can do attacking on
c3 or something probably not yeah and I
should have just stayed him not it's not
doing that stupid activity going for
that which ultimately led to disaster
now that was very stupid loss which I
had a totally safe position and killed
myself black resigns yeah like here what
is absolutely nothing yeah I can just do
I can play this to the end of days and
he has no idea whatsoever but a tribe is
killing is just killing myself just it's
just terrible player
yeah just just nonsense it's just
nonsense in this particular position
it's nonsense and I can really just stay
there's nothing happening ever I have
solved my biggest issues here anyway a
bishop is on b6 already not only seven
or something I've got the night only
five I've got a six covered nothing
happening it's simply nothing happening
you can just stay here I mean I cannot
do much can only hope that he's doing
something something bad but it's the
same the other way around white can only
do something if I'm killing myself which
I probably did with this check the
engine is giving this is still a kind of
okay but it is difficult chatelaine dumb
so here Bishop d 4 is still ok for me
let's see ok ok that computer wants to
take with the bishop I was always
concerned about this move that looks far
more logical getting this night out of
the way but the engine has this reply
which is strong and gives equal
understand that so it's working so then
this is the reason why this is still
kind of playable if I can get rid of the
night yet it's kind of it's
understandable this is given as equal a
it's very helpful to have gone that I
got rid of one night I mean maybe why it
is still a bit better with that's it's
playable at least and here I'm checking
here I'm just toast made age six better
but now that I have too many weaknesses
now his nights are totally on my
weaknesses and my my own night so it
socially by c7 night is very passive so
there was a suicidal game ok well thanks
for watching